sie sind an einem outpost an einem
außenposten der stadt etwa vier
kilometer vom stadtzentrum entfernt hier
haben die territorialen einheiten da
sind die bürger werden hinter mir
checkpoints errichtet um zu verhindern
dass eben russische saboteure oder
andere fallen die hier in die stadt
einfallen und wir stehen hier genau an
einem feld und wir sehen hier die
befestigungsanlagen die jetzt hier
gebaut werden das ist gegen ankommende
panzer wir gehen jetzt mal weiter hier
wird kräftig in den eiskalten boden rein
gehackt wir haben minus vier grad die
stellung die werden jetzt hier nach und
nach ausgebaut weil man rechnet damit
dass von dieser seite von der westseite
die russischen panzer dann auf die stadt
zu
fahren dann um die stadt einzukesseln
das sind alle szenarien wie gehen wir
weiter tief rein und sehen wie hart der
boden hier ist das jetzt hier die
verteidigungsstellung ausgebaut werden
das sollen dann hier wenn man hier ganz
geradeaus durch x filme
sollen dann später die soldaten auch
hier die milizen mit panzerabwehrwaffen
hier kämpfen und wir erwarten die
bevölkerung der erwartet hier sagen wir
nichts gutes dass in den nächsten tagen
wochen das hängt davon ab wie die
schlacht um kiew ausgeht das ist hier
dann zu gefechten kommt die milizen
haben mir gerade berichtet dass nachts
heute nacht wohl mehrere flugzeuge hier
sehr tief über über die stadt geflogen
sind sie konnte nicht wissen nicht ob es
russische waren sie gehen davon aus also
der krieg kommt auch hier näher wir
haben mehrfach luftalarm hier die
menschen sind in den bunker wir haben
gestern nacht ein schläge gehört
ziemlich weit weg allerdings aber es
kommt näher und hier bereitet man sich
eben auf einen kampf vor peter was sind
das für männer die sich da auch im
hintergrund bei dir vorbereiten haben
die familie ist die familie von von den
männern in sicherheit schlafen die dort
tag und nacht arbeiten dort die ganze
nacht beschreibt uns mal ein bisschen
die situation
also alles von allem wir haben hinten es
filme mal durch können wir durch filmen
den kampf stand da waren wir heute
morgen auch trennen da wird trennen
geschlafen das sind meistens lokale
milizen die hier sowieso wohnen und die
gegend hier sehr gut kennen natürlich
haben die familien die frauen arbeiten
alle zusammen
sie kochen für die männer sie schlechten
tarnnetze das ganze im kollektiv und ich
hatte es schon mehrfach immer gesagt es
ist ein irrsinniger zusammenhalt eine
irrsinnige solidarität dieser
territorialen armee die dann im
endeffekt mit der regulären armee hand
in hand zusammen kämpfen will die waffen
die sind allerdings etwas bescheiden das
sind sie haben normale gewehre
jagdgewehre teilweise sie sind
ausgerüstet mit molotow-cocktails aber
das ist genau das was die russen
fürchten denn diese art von
partisanenkampf die ist nicht
kalkulierbar die ist nicht in
irgendeiner form berechenbar und da kann
man mit hightech nicht viel machen die
menschen hier die männer sind ortskundig
und sie sind sie nicht motiviert sie
sind tag und nacht jetzt hier auch im
einsatz um eben hier die stellung
auszubauen und das ist eben diese
motivation diese art von motivation
fürchten die russen natürlich am meisten
weil diese art von motivation haben sie
auf ihrer seite nicht denn die soldaten
die meisten wissen überhaupt nicht was
sie hier in der ukraine machen sollen im
gegensatz zu diesen männern hinter mir
die verteidigen gelernt die verteidigung
ihre familie mit allen mitteln